[Applaudissements]
c'est toute ma vie honnêtement
caroline ouellette a marqué son dernier
but presque 20 ans après cette rumeur la
nouvelle maman est dorénavant à la
retraite après soit par cours inédit
durant lequel elle a rencontré julie
chaud la femme de sa vie
on n'a jamais caché notre union mais on
avait choisi de ne pas en parler de paul
publiciser parce que on trouvait que
c'était plus important de parler de nos
performances d'athlètes de ce qu'on
pouvait apporter à notre société en tant
qu'athlète en tant que leader elles ont
été toutes les deux capitaines de leur
équipe nationale canadienne américaine
ennemi juré elles ont décidé entre leurs
confrontations d'unir leurs destinées
mais ça a été toute une aventure
honnêtement on est ensemble depuis un
peu avant les jeux olympiques de turin
donc 2005 donc ça fait quand même
plusieurs années qu'on sait mais
tellement qu'on a trouvé la façon de
donner de l'espace alors qu'ils
gagnaient je suis 4e caroline a gagné la
médaille d'or aux jo avaient été 4 fois
ses quatre fois de plus que julie
troisième médaille d'argent et une
médaille de bronze des prix médaille
d'or quelle carrière pour jimmy choo les
jeux olympiques de sotchi de devoir la
tristesse fait même le choc pour pour je
lis cet indice depuis caroline et julie
se sont installés à montréal où elles
ont joué ensemble dans la ligue
canadienne
l'idée d'avoir un enfant a mûri puis
juste avant la finale de la coupe
clarkson en 2017
leur choix s'est concrétisée julie il
faut absolument gagner parce que je veux
dire à notre équipe qu'on a gagné avec
trop de joueurs sur la glace
ce jour là caroline savez en secret à
qui elle devait remettre le trophée
les choux ouellette est né le 5 novembre
la nouvelle a été ébruitée sur les
réseaux sociaux
le moment était venu d'exhiber ce
bonheur en famille publiquement que
positif c'est incroyable et commentaires
d'appui ou deux merci d'avoir fait ça
vous nous aidez tellement des gens qui
sont exactement dans cette situation là
je pensais pas pouvoir avoir autant
d'impact montrer aux gens que c'est
possible de s'aimer puis d'avoir un
enfant qui va naître dans l'amour julie
caroline dirige aujourd'hui les stingers
de concordia championne du circuit
universitaire québécois et les moments
de livres ont aussi d'autres projets on
aimerait avoir d'autres enfants puis
julie aimerait c'est aussi vivre cette
expérience là j'adorais est enceinte
honnêtement l'accouchement s'était pas
plus dur que certains entraînements j'ai
au cours de ma carrière
jean françois poirier radio canada
montville
[Musique]